Hi YouTube. Uh, Professor Dang here with
another um update.
So things seem to have quiet down in the
Middle East. Um, but as I said,
all sides, United States, Iran, and
Israel have committed to war. And the
ceasefire, it's really a way to attempt
to control the narrative.
Now, um, as you know, the Iranians have
responded to the American bombing. Um,
the Iranians notify the Americans that
they would send missiles against US
bases, empty US bases in Qatar.
And um that seemed to be the full extent
of the Iranian retaliation.
And Donald Trump was very pleased with
this very tet response.
And um many of you might be wondering
why was the Iranian response so tipp
tippid and so muted. And um there's a
lot of speculation online.
And so what I'll do is I'll I'll offer
you my explanation. If you're fully
committed to war, why would you
uh launch such a tippet response to US
aggression? Well, the main reason is you
want to infuriate
your population. Okay, so um let me
explain what I mean. uh Libby the Roman
historian um he wrote the his entire
history of the Roman Republic and he
wrote about one incident where um a
Roman legion went off to the frontier
and the natives um confronted them and
they were outnumbered. So the Roman
legion built fortifications and every
day uh the natives would come and taunt
uh the Roman soldiers and at this point
um the Roman soldiers really wanted to
go out and fight the natives but the
commanders
um refused. The commanders ordered them
to show restraint and to maintain
defense and as a result the natives
thought that the Romans were cowards. Um
and so the tonic became worse and worse
and it became so bad that the Roman
soldiers were about to mutiny. And at
this point the commanders agreed for the
Roman legion to attack the natives and
the uh Roman legion were so angry uh and
so infuriated and so insulted that they
slaughtered the natives. So that's
what's happening um in Iran today. Uh
the Iranian people are clearly insulted
um and humiliated by this US bombing and
the Iranian government is holding them
back which even makes them more angry
and um as US aggression as Israeli
aggression increases the Iranian
response will become more and more
tippet more and more mute and thus
angering the population to the extent
that uh the population will force the
Iranian regime to declare war on the
United states in Israel. So that's the
game plan moving forward.
Um so I would think that um over the
next month things will be a bit quiet.
There's still going to be a lot of
incidents. Um so the Chinese media is
reporting that um the Iranian uh
intelligence agency has uncovered an
Israeli false flag operation in the
United States. Um, so over the next
couple weeks, we will still see some
news regarding the Middle East, but I
expect things to stay quiet for now. So,
I will use this opportunity to provide
you some, um, important background as to
what's going on in the Middle East. So
um last video I mentioned that um there
are certain elements within the American
Empire uh that want um America to lose a
war against Iran in the Middle East and
they want Israel to become the empire of
the Middle East. And these people these
elements are are called Christian
Zionists.
And so I want to today explain to you um
what Christian Zionism is and how it
fits into this war in the Middle East.
So the tendable term for Christian
Zionism is premillennial
dispensationalist. Okay? So it's a very
hard term um but I'm going to explain
what it means. And by the way um I will
explain a lot of uh new terms in this
video. So I will provide u wiki wiki
links and some background reading in the
description below. Okay. So please check
the description if you want to further
your understanding of the terms I
introduced today. So premillennial
dispensationalism
dispensationalism is premillennial is
the understanding that um when Jesus
returns he will initiate a thousand
years of peace in the world called the
messianic age. Okay, that's that that's
why we have the term premillennial
because um when Jesus returns we will
have a thousand years of peace.
Dispensationalist is the understanding
that the world history is divided into
certain stages. In each stage, the
relationship between God and humans
change. Um, and we are now approaching
the final stage, which is the full
reconciliation with God through the
second coming of Jesus. But for this
second coming to happen, certain
elements need to be in place. Okay, the
first major element is that Israel needs
to be reconstituted as a nation which
has already happened in 1948. Then all
the Jews from around the world have to
return to Israel. Um and then they have
to destroy the Dome of the Rock which is
the third holiest site in Islamic
tradition and build the third temple. Um
then there has to be a war of Gog and
Magog when Israel is besieged by a
fierce enemy. Um and then this will lead
to Agamea sorry uh uh Arga
Madan uh which is the final battle. Uh
and at the very last minute when uh all
hope is lost, when Israel is about to
defeat it, Jesus will return
um and he will initiate the Misianic
age. He will save Israel and he will
initiate the Mesic age. If you're a
Christian, um upon Jesus' return, you
will be immediately sent to heaven. This
is called the rapture.
Um, so that's the idea of Christian
Zionism.
And Christian Zionism, as I explained
before, is one of the main drivers of
this war in the Middle East.
And if Christian Zionists have their
way, then certain things will happen.
Okay. The most important thing that must
happen is the United States send ground
troops against Iran. Because as I
mentioned, if the United States were to
send ground troops into Iran, the
American empire would fall and uh which
will give birth to the to the empire of
Israel. This is important because in the
Christian Zionist framework, America is
not involved in this prophecy. So you
need to take America out of this
equation somehow. Okay? So that's the
first thing that um must happen. Second
thing that must happen um is the Dome of
the Rock must be destroyed.
Um if the Dome of the Rock were
destroyed, um the Jews could rebuild the
third temple. But most but more
importantly,
um it would unify the Islamic world
against Israel, thus initiating the war
of Gog and Magog. Another thing that
must happen is the Jews um must return
to Israel. And right now
most Jews are living very nice lives in
the Western world. So why would they
want to return to Israel? Well, the
answer is um America has been defeated
uh in Iran and Americans are pissed
about this loss. And so
who do they blame? um who do they
persecute
and who will who who would be the
scapegoats and so you have this global
surge of anti-semitism and so now you
have um major Jewish intellectuals
coming out and say listen we should all
return to Israel because that's where
we'll most be saved. Okay. So um if I'm
correct and and I if I'm correct in
believing that Christian Zionism is a
very powerful force in the world then
these three things will happen over the
next few years. Uh a US grand invasion
of Iran the Donald Rock will be
destroyed somehow. I don't know how. Um
and the third thing is a uh movement to
um return Jews to Israel.
Um, so why is Christian Zionism so
strong? Well, what I will show you today
is Christian Zionism is embedded
into the very foundations of the
AngloAmerican Empire. It's been there
since the beginning. And it's been there
since the beginning thanks to the
contributions of one man, Isaac Newton.
So let me tell you about Isaac Newton
and then you will better understand how
Christian Zionism came to being and how
it influenced the Anglo-American Empire.
Um Isaac Newton as you know was
probably the most brilliant man who ever
lived. He was an extraordinary man who
lived an extraordinary life. Um he was
born into a common family. His family
was not nobility, not royalty. Uh very
common. His father died when he was very
young and his mother remarried and
essentially abandoned Newton.
But Newton was extremely gifted student
and he eventually got scholarship to
stud at Cambridge University where he
began to make the major contributions
development of science. Um he made major
contributions to optics. He invented
calculus. um he um discovered the three
laws of planetary motion which proved
conclusively uh once and for all that
that our solar system was helocentric as
opposed to geocentric. In many ways
Newton embodied the sonic revolution.
Um when he died he was given a state
funeral. Only the second person in
British history at that time uh who was
non- royalty to be given a state
funeral. Um and he was one of the and
and he was uh one of the only scientists
to be given a state funeral. Um and even
today uh the British remember um Isaac
Newton as the most brilliant um
Englishman who ever um lived. But there
are three things that you may not know
about um Isaac Newton. And once I
explain these three things, then you
have a much more um
uh complete understanding of this
brilliant man. The first thing that you
probably don't know about him is that um
he was fascinated by the occult. He was
a major practitioner of the occult,
mainly alchemy.
Um so um Newton spent most of his life
in search of the philosopher stone. Um
because the philosopher stone promised
the ex the um elixir of immortality
which would grant immortality. It also
promised to turn lead into gold and
Newton was
positive that existed. So he spent um
most of his life in search of it. And we
know about this because 1930s the
economist John Maynor kings um he bought
um Newton's papers on an auction and he
really believed that within these papers
he would discover mathematical secrets
of the universe. Instead uh what he what
he discovered was all this religious
gibberish from Newton. News spent most
of his life studying the Bible and
trying to figure out um the divine
messages embedded in the uh Bible. So um
if you were to ask Newton
like what is your profession? Newton
would never say he was a scientist um or
a philosopher. He would say first and
foremost he was a theologian. He was
most interested in discovering the mind
of God.
And that's why he developed his
mathematical and physical systems in
order to better decipher the mind of
God. Okay. So let me give you an example
of this. Um at this time in history most
Christians understood that history was
theological. Um theological comes from
the Greek tilos which means purpose. So
history is moving towards the end which
is second coming of of of Christ.
Newton's great great insight was to
understand that if history is indeed
theological
then it has um structure and order and
therefore it can be expressed
mathematically
and so if you can figure out the
mathematical underpinnings of the world
then you've proven that history is
theological and therefore you've proven
that God uh exists. Newton's three laws
of motions, right? Let's let let's let's
re we re summarize Newton's three laws
of motions. Law number one, things that
are at rest stay at rest. Number two,
force is force equals mass times
acceleration. Number three, for every
action, there must be an equal reaction.
Okay? So what people don't understand is
these three laws are not physical laws.
There are first and foremost an
ontological
argument which proves existence of God.
So the first law things that are rest
must stay at rest. Okay. So we can
imagine that at the beginning of time
everything was at rest. If everything's
at rest it can't move by itself
according to the first law. Therefore
something must have moved things to put
things in motion. And this is what
Aristotle calls the prime mover.
Um second and third law implies that
there's a structure and order and
purpose to the universe. And who
designed the structure, order and
purpose? It must be God. Okay. So what's
interesting is that these three laws of
motion um they prove that God exists but
much more importantly they are the basis
for a new religion, a new religious
movement called theism. And theism is
important uh because theism is the main
religion of the founding fathers of
America. Okay. So um having proven that
God in fact does exist, Newton's next
step is
what does God want? What is God's
purpose? Well, for him it was easy to
understand God's purpose. Read the
Bible. So Newton would spend decades
um reading the Bible and trying to and
trying to imagine its mathematical
underpinnings. For him, every sentence
was a mathematical formula.
And he was trying to take the Bible and
compare and contrast it with history.
And um he wrote a book, it was not
published in his lifetime, but it was
published after his death. It was called
um um observations upon the prophecies
of Daniel and uh the apocalypse of St.
John and um it's it's something you you
have to look at. Okay. So so what what
I'm going to do is I'm going to put a
link down description below which will
um and you can read it online for free.
Okay. So um this is a major work and
it's a foundational text for Christian
Zionism because it argues first of all
that history is theological that God has
a purpose and second of all this is
really important
um the Bible is literal. Okay. So even
though Daniel and John were different
people they both as prophets spoke the
mind of God. They were divinely inspired
and so whatever they wrote came from God
himself. So by examining their
prophecies, you are deciphering God's
purpose for humanity. Okay? And this is
a foundation for Christian Zionism.
Okay? Okay. So that's the first thing
you need to understand about um Newton
that he was first and foremost um a
theologian and not a scientist. Okay.
Second thing that you must um understand
about Newton is that he was a member of
secret societies in England at that
time. Now today when we think of secret
societies we think of nefarious
underground conspiracies. At that time
secret societies were actually very
common and very well accepted. Secret
societies were platforms for men of
education of wealth and of status to get
together to engage in religious
speculation outside the purview of the
Anglican church. Um at that time the
Angling church had an orthodoxy and by
law you could not transgress transgress
against this orthodoxy. So for example
uh Newton got a lot into a lot of
trouble uh during his lifetime because
he did not believe in the holy trinity.
He thought that Jesus was not co-equal
to God. He thought that Jesus was
subordinate to God and this was a heresy
at that time. So um new Newton um got in
a lot of trouble but he had powerful
friends, powerful backers and so they
bailed him out from the uh church
authorities. Um so um these societies
were a platform for people to discuss
religious matters. Um they also had
their origins uh from the Knights
Templars. The night templars during the
crusades were in Jerusalem. And because
they were in Jerusalem, they could
engage in uh world religions
like Zorastronism, like um m like Islam,
uh like Judaism, like paganism. And as
such they uh and because these these
were extremely educated men uh with deep
intellectual curiosity uh they collected
all the secret teachings that they were
exposed to in Jerusalem and they brought
it back to them in Europe and so they
ran a foul of the Catholic Church which
outlaw them eventually but their
teachings went underground in and they
became embedded in these secret
societies. Okay. So when Newton joined
the secret societies and when he was
able to discover the laws of the
universe, well I imagine that these men
celebrate Newton as a prophet, as a
messiah, as a chosen one, as someone who
um reveal who would who would reveal the
secret uh teachings of God to the world.
And because the world was not ready for
these teachings, then they would make it
their mission uh to keep it secret and
wait for the day when they could reveal
these teachings to the world. Um so
Newton's teachings that um God has a
purpose and this purpose is literally
embedded into the Bible and uh this um
this purpose will lead to second coming
of of Christ. It now becomes the
framework for these secret societies and
as they spread to America
um it becomes embedded in the secret
societies of America as well. And guess
who were members of the secret
societies? The founding fathers of
America. Right? So um that's second
thing you need to know about Newton that
he was uh a member of the secret
societies who celebrated him and who
treated his theological understandings
as the word of God. Okay. And the third
thing that you have to um understand
about Newton is for 30 years he was
master of the royal mint and he was in
and he was his purpose was to maintain
the sanctity, the value um and the
credibility of royal coinage against
counterfeits. Um and so to deal with
counterfeits he set up a network of
spies to identify to identify these
counterfeits.
um sometimes to torture them for
information and for the most egregious
offenders um they'll be executed. Okay.
So in other words, Newton established
England's
very first intelligence agency,
intelligence apparatus. In 1865, the
United States Treasury Department
established a secret service. What was
their job? Their job was to identify um
counterfeits. Why were they called
Secret Service? Because the Treasury
Department didn't want people to know
they existed. Because if they existed,
it meant that counterfeiting was a huge
problem in America, which which it was
at that time, which is it still is
today. And so that would undermine the
credibility of the currency. Okay. So,
um, so Newton had his own intelligence
agency. So in many ways Newton
um built the foundations
of the British Empire which eventually
became the Anglo-American Empire which
controls the world today and it and so
um let's summarize and I'll give you
three takeaways from today's talk I want
you to remember. Okay, the first talk
the first takeaway is
because Isaac Newton saw himself as a
prophet because he was he was convinced
that um only through divine favor could
he arise from being a poor abandoned
child to becoming one of the leading
intellectuals of British society, the
leading scientist of British society. It
could only be through divine favor. Um
then he had a mission to spread God's
message and that message um will become
the foundations of Christian Zionism. So
Christian Zionism is embedded into the
very fabric, the very foundation
of the Anglo-American Empire. Okay,
that's the first major takeaway. Second
major takeaway is
Israel is a creation of the
AngloAmerican
Empire.
Zionism is a creation of Christian
Zionism.
Um, which leads us to the third
takeaway. Judaism and Zionism are not
the same thing. Christian Zionism and
Judaism are in fundamental conflict. Let
me explain why. The people who are most
who are most opposed to the creation of
the state of Israel are Orthodox Jews.
Because in their tradition, in their
religion, um the plan is for God to send
a Messiah, the anointed one who will
lead the Jewish people. And this Messiah
will bring the Jews back to the promised
land, create the nation of Israel, uh
build the third temple, and create the
Messianic age. Okay? The Jews don't know
who this Mazai is, and they don't know
when he will come. And so they must be
patient, have faith in God.
Christian Zionism is an attempt to
manipulate history, manipulate God to
force the second coming of Jesus. In the
mind of Christian Zionist, if the um
nation of Israel is reconstituted, if
all the Jews return to Israel, if the
third temple is built, if there's a war
of Gog and Magog, then Jesus is forced
to return. They will force the hand of
God and create the Messianic age. So for
Orthodox Jews, this is a blasphemy. This
is um counterfeiting. This is this is
the export. This is stealing their
religion and that's why Orthodox Jews
are most opposed to the state of um
Israel.
So um I know this was um an extremely
um controversial, very confusing talk.
So, what I'll do again is I will um in
the descript description below um put
all the links and the references you
will need to truly understand um
Christian Zionism. So, please look at
um Newton's book uh prophecies
upon sorry observations upon the
prophecies of um Daniel and the populace
of St. John. Uh please look at the
Scoffield Bible which it which um um
frames the Bible in the lens of
Christian Zionism
and please look at wiki entries for
Christian Zionism pre premillennial
dispensationalism
um Newton. Okay. So um if you really
want to understand what's going on in
the Middle East, then you really need to
get a good uh handle on these um ideas.
I'm sure this talk has raised a lot of
questions for you. Some of you like why
is Christian Zionism so powerful? Some
of you may disagree and say what's
driving this war in the Middle East is
not Christian Zionism. It's um
international finance. It's a city of
London. It's um the Great Reset. Um it's
American Empire. Okay. Um so what I will
do in my next talk is explain to you
these things are not mutually exclusive.
They're all one thing. And you can make
the argument that they are one big
conspiracy. And the only people who
don't know that this is a great
conspiracy are the conspirators
themselves. Okay? I will in in in my
next talk I use game theory to explain
to you what's going on and when I do
then things will be extremely clear to
you as to why Christian Zionism is able
to drive the history of the Middle East.
Okay. What I'll also show you next in u
in my next talk is that
um
Christian Zionism
um what's happened in the Middle East.
It's happened before and it will happen
again. Okay. So, 1,500 years ago in the
Middle East, it seemed as though
biblical prophecy was about to be
fulfilled. The world was at war against
each other. Empires were fighting over
Jerusalem and the millions were dying.
The world seemed to be ending. It really
seemed the end of history. And at this
time, the Jews were praying for the
Messiah.
and they really believed the Messiah had
come to them. Okay, a man came and they
really believed he was the anointed one
and he was able to rally not just Jews
but everyone around him. He was so
charismatic and it really seemed as
though the meant age would um come and
these Jews were willing to die for for
him. That's how much they believed in
him. Um
this man's name well actually we don't
know this man's name but today we refer
to this man as Muhammad okay Muhammad
was the Messiah of the Jews. So in my in
in my next video I will explain to you
uh how this came about.
Um just a quick announcement.
Um, I want to thank everyone for
subscribing to my channel. I'm really
flattered by all the attention, but I'm
not really um set up for this. Uh, this
summer I was I I brought my two kids
back to Toronto and I uh and I'm every
day I'm I'm from like 8:00 a.m. until
400 p.m. I take them outside to play.
So, I really don't have that much time
to make these videos. But at the same
time, I want to do the best possible job
in presenting uh really interesting uh
perspectives to you about what's going
on in the world today. I I if you if you
spend the time to watch my videos, then
I have an obligation to make sure these
videos are insightful for you. Um so, um
I'm going to need more time to spend on
these videos. So,
um I'm sorry, but I might have to take a
pause for about 2 weeks in order to um
really uh delve deep into the research
necessary in order to create the next
video.
But if this war in the Middle East
breaks out again for whatever reason, I
don't think it will, but if it breaks
out for whatever reason, then rest
assured I will make a video helping you
analyze what's going on um and giving
you some insight as to why this is
happening and where the and where things
might be going. Okay, so um thanks so
much for watching. I really appreciate
it and I will see you next time.